Bulgaria is a small country in the
Balkans which since its independence in
1878 has changed shape many times unlike
most countries Bulgaria repeatedly
conquered and lost the same lands
without much consolidation which raises
the pretty obvious question why why has
Bulgaria lost so much land over the
course of his existence so modern
Bulgaria came into existence in 1878
after a series of revolts in the Balkan
region against ottoman rule there this
precipitated a war between the Russians
and the Ottomans and to put it mildly
the Russians won but they knew that they
weren't free to just take as much
ottoman territory as they wanted because
it would upset the other powers with
interests in the region as such Russian
leadership came up with the clever
compromise they would only receive a
small amount of Ottoman land and instead
the primary territorial gains would go
to Russia's new ally Bulgaria it was
agreed in the Treaty of San Stefano that
the newly semi-independent Bulgaria
would look like this the Russians had
hoped that Bulgaria would soon become a
client state of theirs and would thus
lease its ports to Russian warships
thereby giving his access to the
Mediterranean without having to deal
with the Ottomans whenever they wanted
to leave the Black Sea it won't surprise
you to know that the other great Powers
saw through this and quickly demanded
that the new bulk area be reshaped in a
way that would maintain the balance of
power Russia didn't really have much of
a choice and so Bulgaria was reduced to
this its print soon afterwards was also
allowed to rule this ottoman territory
rumelia but for many Bulgarian leaders
they had seen what Bulgaria could be and
so that was what they wanted in 1885
Bulgaria United with romelia and in 1908
it declared its independence as a
kingdom under SAR Ferdinand the first
and Ferdinand had one simple objective
rebuild greater Bulgaria and there was
only one way to do this politely asking
also war and boy was there a lot of War
to come the first was in 1912 when these
nations despite their long-standing
dislike of each other teamed up to force
the Ottomans out of the Balkans this war
called the first Balkan War went very
well and the Ottomans lost these lands
with these going to Bulgaria naturally
this boy the Bulgarian mood so this
military winning streak was obviously
going to continue Bulgarian leadership
had decided that hadn't been given
enough during the previous war and that
both Greece and Serbia were holding onto
lands that weren't theirs as such two
months after the first Balkan War had
come to an end Bulgarian troops attacked
Serbia in Greece this didn't exactly go
to plan and when Bulgarian forces got
bogged down Romania capitalized a
marched South with Little Resistance
again sensing weakness the Ottomans
invaded from the south and losing a war
on four fronts meant that the bulgarians
had no chance in the peace negotiations
the bulgarians gave these lands to
Serbia Romania Greece and the Ottomans
which really soured the Bulgarian
national mood since who knew when the
next opportunity to retake these lands
would present itself fortunately for
Ferdinand not Franz Ferdinand that is
the next year saw the start of World War
One which Bulgaria soon joined on the
side of the Central Powers it had been
promised these lands from Serbia and at
its height Bulgaria grew to this size
that was of course just months before it
surrendered to the on taunt and
subsequently lost all of this it won't
surprise you to know that the bulgarians
weren't happy with their losses and so
20 years later when the second world war
was ongoing the bulgarians Mostly
because they were afraid of being on the
wrong side of Germany and also because
they saw an opportunity join the axis
over the course of the war Bulgaria
gained all of these lands which they
held until they came down with a case of
the Red Army after the war Bulgaria was
stripped all of its gains except for
southern debrusia Bulgaria was allowed
to keep the land that it took from
Romania because both had been members of
the axis and also they were now both
communist puppet states of the USSR and
Stalin told Romanians to drop it and so
drop it they did and with that Bulgaria
maintained these borders which it still
has to this day I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonet Kelly moneymaker
Sky Chappelle katowitzka Andy mcgeehy
Alex Schwinn AF Firefly Marcus arsner
Spencer Lightfoot wire hockey Marvin
cassow Captain psydog boogly Wiggly
commune Winston K wood Gustav Swan
Khalid Alderwood Maki Paskowski the
macquapa Anthony Beckett calling Dr
Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard Coppertone
shewenin spinning three plates words
about books podcast rod D Martin Jim
Stromberg Miss is it and Charles the
first